hi there
hello martin
so you are an app modernization solution
manager at google right and you have an
app for us to modernize today
yes we have a legacy two-tier node.js
application running on a vm
and we want to modernize it using
serverless technologies
the vm is costing us money 24 7.
also we have to assign someone with the
right operation skills to maintain it
we'd like google to do that for us
all right and does the team running this
app no containers
uh the team has started the
containerization journey they considered
communities but they don't have enough
experience with that
a lot of organizations are in that place
let's migrate the app for them using
cloud run which doesn't require them to
learn kubernetes
[Music]
this is what the app ui looks like
it's a simple to-do list application
let me add a couple of to-do list items
about modernizing this application
got it
what does the architecture look like
here it is a web front-end a node.js
backend
and a mongodb database
the html and javascript for web
front-end is served by the node.js
backend
does the app use server-side sessions or
any other storage outside the database
no it's a simple app where all the users
see the same content
all the data is in the database
let's keep the database as is for now
we'll move the node.js backend and the
serving of html to cloud run
then we can shut down that vm
makes sense uh let's look at the
database machine for a minute
we need to set up a serverless vpe
connector from cloudrun to this database
right
let me click the serverless vpc
connector option here and then i'll
create one
i'll give it a name
and i'll use all the default settings
and now let's create it
this will take a minute so let's get
started on the next step let's have a
look at the source code here
this is a git repo which is good most of
the enterprises want their code
protected
especially when the development is done
offshore or remotely
think curvy right
i'm going to use a browser
browser-based editor that works like vs
code
but doesn't depend on my workstation
good idea
editing the code in the cloud also means
that it doesn't matter what version of
node.js npm etc that you and i have on
our laptops
right
first i'll open the google cloud shell
here which gives me a command line in
the cloud
now that i have a command line
i can
run a git clone of this repo
all right and then you'll edit it in the
cloud yeah
i'll click here to start the cloud
editor
this editor looks and feels similar to a
traditional editor
like vs code running on my laptop
but it runs in the cloud
all right the cloud run docs say that
our code should listen on a port defined
by the port environment variable
yeah here it is
looks like the existing code already
does that so we don't have to change
anything
if the port had been hard coded here we
had to change it
right
how does the code connect to the
database via
let's see
looks like it reads the connection
parameters from the environment
variables
as well
who wrote this application know what
they were doing
yeah well done
um veer uh do you think we should write
a docker file and build a container
ourselves for this app well
we could it's not very hard
but the team isn't very comfortable with
containers yet so let's deploy from
source code and use uh build packs
instead
um yeah that makes sense it's a node app
so we should probably run npm installed
first
okay doing so now um
now
that all the packages have been
installed i will prep the gcloud run
deploy command
right
we need to tell cloudron about the vpc
connector and the environment variables
absolutely we could also set all that in
google cloud console but the team wants
things done from the command line so
they can automate it later
here is the gcloud run command with all
the environment variables with database
connection parameters
i'm also adding the vpc connector
very nice
let's run it uh it's asking me a few
follow-up questions here
about uh region and such i'll answer
them
all right looks like the build is
running
uh let me open the build log here in the
cloud console
uh-huh yeah it looks like things are
happening here
the build pack is taking our source code
and building a container from it without
us having to create a docker file or or
know anything about containers
that makes this easy for developers
looks like the build is done now
um
look at the container register please
uh-huh
ah there's our container
now let's go to the cloud run in the
console let's see
uh yep there's our deployed service
the url is shown here let's hit it
hmm um look at that the app is working
and we are seeing the same to-do list
items in the ui as before
when this app was running in the virtual
machine and now i can mark these two
to-do list items that i created before
as done
right uh that reminds me uh we don't
really need that virtual machine anymore
do we
we don't uh let's turn it off
all right i'm navigating to virtual
machines
uh there it is
and i'm deleting it
feels good doesn't it
removed code from virtual machine that
was costing us money 24x7
to cloud run where we pay for cpu and
memory usage only when the request is
being served
if we get less traffic at night we pay
less and if we get no traffic on
weekends we don't pay anything anything
at all
right and even if the container is ready
to serve requests we don't pay anything
until an actual request comes in
also we don't have to assign anyone to
maintain the virtual machine
uh vir will the team build new versions
of this web app
yeah i think they probably will need a
ci cd pipeline for that but that will be
a story for another day sounds good to
me thank you for watching everyone if
you have any questions for veer or me
let us know in the comments also let us
know what you thought of today's episode
and other serverless topics you'd like
to see in the future
until next time
[Music]